hello good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast it's another setback for the
travel sector from tuesday anyone
entering the uk will have to take a
pre-departure covert test the government
says it's a temporary measure following
an increase in cases of the new omicron
strain linked to foreign travel
well the move has been welcomed by
labour but travel officials describe it
as a hammer blow
let's take you through the latest rules
from 4am on tuesday anyone traveling to
the uk from countries not on the red
list has to take a pre-departure test a
maximum of 48 hours before leaving
that's regardless of their vaccination
status
nigeria in west africa has become the
11th country to be added to the
government's red travel list
and as in the case with those traveling
from other redless countries only
british and irish nationals will be
allowed into the uk and must isolate in
a government-managed quarantine hotel
for 10 days
these new rules follow last week's
announcement that all international
travelers are now required to take a pcr
test upon arrival in the uk
where the new rules come as a further 25
cases of the omicron variant have been
identified in england bringing the total
to 129.
scotland had also identified a further
case taking the total there to 30
and as it stands just one case has been
identified in wales and there are no
confirmed cases in northern ireland
that means a total of omicron cases
across the uk is a hundred and sixty
sky stan whitehead reports now on the
impacts of the new variant
as omicron spreads
the borders are tightening yet again
from tuesday anyone arriving in the uk
will need to provide a negative pcr or
lateral flow test
taken no more than 48 hours before
departure we're seeing increasing number
of cases linked to travel and again
we've always said we will act swiftly if
we need to if the changing data requires
that and that's why we've decided to
bring in this change of course it is
something that's going to particularly
uh hit people that were had travel plans
and that is hugely unfortunate but i
think the vast majority of people
understand exactly why it is important
to take action
receiving her booster jabs scotland's
first minister nicola sturgeon has been
calling for the reintroduction of
pre-departure tests
but those in the travel industry say
it's a step backwards
i'm afraid it's not good news for the
travel sector and it's certainly not
good news for airlines who were hoping
to benefit from an uplift really over
the christmas period we're going back
several months it's taking us back
effectively to may the worst hit sector
will be the inbound sector both tourism
leisure tourism and business travel for
those coming into the uk who simply
won't bother they won't want to take all
these tests so just drop it down by your
side for me nice and relaxed thank you
the announcement comes as the government
ramps up its rollout of covid boosters
hopefully you know this vaccine there is
some evidence so far that it is still
gonna
still help so hopefully the big push
before january is gonna hopefully solve
it we've been waiting for our period
until we could book as soon as we could
book
so we're very keen to come down i have
to say the organisation as with our
first two jabs has been fantastic
the prime minister says vaccination
centers will be popping up like
christmas trees in the coming days and
while more jabs are going into arms
there's also a fresh push to get
expectant mothers vaccinated
the phone calls are being told that um
excuse me sorry
that i may not survive a new video
released by the nhs hears from mothers
who suffered complications while giving
birth due to covid
emma hockridge is due in february and
contracted kovid just last month
having just had her booster she has a
clear message to other expectant moms
speak to my wife and get independent
advice
not look online not read stories horror
stories on facebook
but to get independent advice from them
because they have all the data they put
the history of the science
the booster campaign comes as the nhs is
already facing winter pressure while
millions of extra jabs are the main
defense at home
the threat of omicron coming in from
abroad
means tougher travel rules
are back
dan whitehead sky news
well let's go live now to heathrow and
to our correspondent shingi mararike and
showing you the rules for travellers
changing very quickly
they are good morning those changes will
affect people traveling here into
heathrow and airports across the country
and they mean from 4 a.m on tuesday
people traveling into the uk will have
to take a lateral flow or a pcr test
before they depart where they are coming
from and also it's interesting these
changes are taking place off the back of
this new information about the
incubation period of the omicron variant
it is thought that the gap between
people being infected with the variant
and them being able to pass it on is
shorter than other variants of the virus
we now know also off the back of that
announcement by satya javid that there
will be an addition to the red list as
well nigeria will be put on that list of
countries as well the government is
pointing to the fact that there were 21
cases of the new variant linked to
travel from nigeria unsurprisingly those
changes by the government have been met
with fury by the travel industry who
called it a hammer blow over the course
of the very busy christmas period the
british travel association
their chafe executive come up with a
very punchy statement earlier today
saying that public safety is a priority
but businesses will fail travelers will
be stranded and livelihoods devastated
by the lack of coherent plans from
government the government says that
these changes are only temporary while
they understand a bit more about the
omicron variant and they gather more
scientific information i think it's fair
to say that the travel industry will
certainly hope so
xing thank you
our reports this morning suggests that
there could soon be a new treatment for
coronavirus patients
sky news understands a letter has gone
out to health officials detailing the
rollout of an antiviral pill for anyone
who tests positive for the virus the
sunday telegraph claims the drug called
malnu pyruvate could soon be offered to
the most vulnerable patients
now the sentences for the killers of
six-year-old arthur labinjo hughes will
be reviewed by the attorney general to
determine whether they were too low
this comes after sully hall mp julian
knight said that the jail terms given to
arthur's father thomas hughes and his
partner emma tustin were far too lenient
the prime minister is also expected to
launch a national inquiry into the
murder to try to prevent such a tragedy
happening again
our political correspondent rob powell
is in westminster for us now so rob just
tell us more about what we know about
this possible inquiry
not a lot yet actually um vanessa we
know that there is potentially going to
be some sort of announcement today into
a wider investigation the sunday times
are reporting this morning uh that that
will be
a wider inquiry ordered by the prime
minister that will pull in various other
public
bodies to examine their part
in the tragic murder
of arthur lobenzo hughes so that could
involve
bodies like the police
schools social services probation
watchdogs
as well i think if it is announced they
will have plenty um to look at first and
foremost will clearly be why uh warnings
from members of arthur's family and also
teachers were apparently not heeded why
social workers had gone to the home days
before he was killed
and essentially given the situation um
the all clear we've heard from
a former conservative minister this week
saying the social workers need to be
supported to essentially be able to dig
deeper into concerning cases and ask
more
probing and sometimes awkward questions
i think another part of this could
potentially be the impact of covert
policies and lockdown a lot of this
abuse happened
when schools were shut and of course his
murder happened towards the end of the
first set of lockdown um restrictions we
heard a lot at the time about um the
potential for lockdown and schools
closing down to um increase abuse behind
closed doors and then i think finally
attention may well be put
on whether social services and child
protection departments have the
resources that they need local councils
that run these sorts of services have
seen huge cuts over the last um 10 years
lord laming who
conducted the inquiry into the deaths of
victoria columbia and
baby peter connolly
has said in the last day or two that he
believes cuts to resources and funding
has had an impact over the last 10 years
now i don't think it's any surprise that
boris johnson will want to try and be
swift and move fast to announce
something
like this the next couple of days i
think we will see an increased focus
on law and order with other unconnected
policy announcements around that
ultimately i guess what matters is what
politicians do rather than what they say
and whether it goes far enough to stop
any more tragic incidents like the one
we've seen in solihull
robin westminster thank you
in other news at least 13 people have
died and dozens more have been injured
after a volcano erupted in indonesia
well let's speak to our southeast asia
correspondent shawn robbins who joins us
now siobhan just bring us up to date
with the latest
well we're starting to get pictures from
that disaster zone now pictures showing
houses submerged in thick mud uh cars
only visible from the tops of their
roofs
after the volcano erupted yesterday on
the island of java taking many residents
by surprise more than 900 people have
had to flee their homes we know 13
people have been killed more than 50
people in hospitals some of them with
very very severe burns from the hot lava
and then also problems with this cold
lava which is mixed with rivers has
rushed through villages bringing this
thick mud with it taken out a bridge as
well and the rain is continuing to
hamper the rescue efforts we know that
the indonesian air force is now on the
scene helping rescue teams but very very
difficult conditions there on the island
of java indonesia
siobhan thank you
the more than four and a half thousand
homes remain without power this morning
nine days after storm irwin the prime
minister has spoken by phone to those
leading the emergency response
stephen bridget is a councillor in the
northumberland town of rothbury who
joins us now thanks for your time this
morning what's the situation like where
you are at the moment
good morning vanessa and at the moment
basically we were down to around about
the last 120 150 properties at the close
of play yesterday
we had significant rainfall and wind hit
again last night and that pretty much
wiped out all of the good work that had
been achieved for the last three or four
days and we're now back up to over 600
properties that are still without power
and some of them went off around about i
think it was about six seven o'clock
last night and they're still yet to
return on
um so the number of homes going up there
now they still off the power there they
are as of this morning they are still
off the power and we've we've got
significant surface water flooding
happening uh in this area this morning
as well so some of the roads are
starting to flood because we've
literally pretty much had constant
rainfall now for 12 to 14 hours i
haven't had a chance to check the river
levels but it started off as snow and
then it's progressed into heavy rainfall
with winds
i spoke to tim ferran who's mp for
westmoreland and lonsdale on this
program yesterday and he
criticized the um government's response
but he did praise the local response in
the area
how would you say the response has been
so far
from a local level i would i would
absolutely agree for the fire and rescue
service the county council the mountain
rescue uh northumbria police has been
absolutely fantastic but in my view a
major incident should have been called
earlier on in the week and i think that
came down to more politics than actual
practicalities in my view
do you think that boris johnson should
have been there at this stage no i think
a major incident can only be declared at
a local level uh by the local authority
and i think uh my understanding is from
as a member of the local authority
politics may have played a decision in
it but i i believe officers eventually
took control and said no we're declaring
it and and that's where we are but um
that will be investigated at a later
date
i'm trying to get a sense of who's
affected at the moment and where they
are
where they're getting any support
because obviously they won't be able to
stay in their homes will they
no so well we've got around about 20
residents who are in alternative
accommodation and that option is
available to any other resident that
needs alternative accommodation we've
got thousands of candles batteries water
logs kindling which are available at
collection points in rothbury and
whittington so anyone that wants to come
down to rothbury today and collect it
the welfare center will be open
providing hot drinks and hot food and
and with the latest power cut and
increasing by more than well three four
times now uh
we're expecting a pretty
good number to come through the door
today if northern power grid can't get
those back on that they've got back on
earlier this week
now the chief executive of germ
criticized the lack of communication
between customers and the power
companies um somebody whom i also spoke
to yesterday what is it that you're
hearing from the people you're speaking
to how is the communication now so
significant power cuts are a regular
thing in this area so i've got all of
the direct contact numbers for the for
the the the ladies and gentlemen at
northern power grid that normally deal
with this area so from my perspective
it's been very easy to contact them but
i know for resident and i've been trying
to update residents on my social media
as a result of that but for residents
themselves the website the contact
center uh is absolutely next to useless
there are waiting times of an hour
sometimes the website doesn't load and
the information on it is automated it's
not accurate and so the best
intelligence you can get is from the
engineers on the ground reporting back
to their managers and that's who i've
been speaking to
i mean with what you just said do you
think that the uh there are you are
prepared if something like this happens
again because we're going to see more
and more of this aren't we especially
with climate change
we've had significant flooding we've had
significant winter storms uh we've had a
week with no gas we are a pretty tough
and resilient community in this area and
and i we are absolutely prepared i can't
speak for the rest of uh
northumberland um but but certainly in
this neck of the woods we are prepared
we're tough we're resilient and we've
knocked on all of the doors that have
been off this week to check on residents
more than three times now and and we
will need to do that again with the
increase in in numbers of power
properties that were cut off from power
as of last night
so how's your day looking today then
where are you going in the area what's
on your schedule i'm averaging in about
three hours night sleep since last
friday um as you can probably tell so
today we open the rest center at nine
o'clock and it's going to be a pretty
long day we've got fire service police
personnel and military personnel
arriving again today we will
we're waiting for the latest data from
northern power grid that will tell us
which exact properties are off again and
it will be a job we will be door
knocking on every one of those
properties because for some of them with
landlines still being down and no mobile
phone reception it really is the only
way to communicate with them
excellent and now we can just show you
the pictures now which is the northern
power grid website that's just showing
you the extents of the damage that's
caused at the moment and those are
ongoing power cuts that you can see
across northern england that you can see
at the moment very extensive i mean
stephen you've just touched on your day
ahead there so it's looking like a very
busy day for you
an exceptionally busy day um i would say
that i had a look at the northern power
grid website just before and some of the
information on that isn't quite accurate
um
there are areas that are back on that
are marked as being off but then there
are a significant number of areas that
are marked as being on who are actually
off as a result of the power cut last
night but yes it is going to be a busy
day we will be delivering uh firewood as
well and candles and batteries and we've
managed to obtain some butane gas
cylinders for camping stoves and gas
heaters for residents so we will be
coordinating that with northumbria
police the fire service and the military
who were a fantastic support yesterday
and really did complement the local
services that we've got on the ground
here
steven bridges councillor in the
northumberland town of rothbury thank
you thank you
welcome back at the 2019 general
election boris johnson swept into power
off the back of red wall landslide and
he's vowed to repay those who voted for
him a government white paper on
levelling up in britain is due before
christmas but what it takes to help
rebuild northern towns and cities and
what's the potential political fallout
from the government if it fails to
deliver for its on its promises trevor
phillips reports now from humberside
the old market town of ghoul in the east
riding of yorkshire
home to britain's most inland port
once at the heart of britain's coal
export drive
like many northern towns ghoul has
suffered from a steady post-industrial
decline
just a few miles away along the humber
they're building the platform for ghouls
future prosperity
the german transport company siemens is
developing this site into a 200 million
pound manufacturing facility
they have orders to build the next
generation of rolling stock for
customers including the london
underground and the company is dug in
for the long haul
we are a business to community being in
the community working in the community
taking the knowledge we have imparting
that into the community inspiring people
giving giving people a pride and a sense
of place i think that's been lacking in
many places
siemens promotion of a primary
engineering program to help get these
kids trained up in the necessary skills
for jobs at the factory is already
proving to be a big hit
if big companies like siemens keep
investing in places like google then i'm
really optimistic because they give
opportunity they give opportunities for
um young people
to invest in their own area if they want
to because there's the structures there
to do that and they can work at any
level
it's almost impossible not to be
uplifted by the optimism that we found
here it's not just the jobs or the new
infrastructure it is the sense that this
town
has found a purpose again
and that it will have status and respect
and even a bit of love
but to make leveling up work this is
going to have to happen in hundreds of
places across the country
and if it doesn't
boris johnson and his government
are going to pay a pretty high political
price
it's high stakes for the prime minister
as well
because this has been what he'll be
remembered by does he make leveling up a
reality he wants it to be a reality but
can he push it through government can he
push it through treasury and there's
real question marks there and a
government that can't deliver more
successful towns is a government that
will have a lot of questions to answer
at the next general election boris
johnson has already marked his place in
history as the prime minister who
succeeded in his promise to deliver
brexit
a new government white paper on
levelling up is due this side of
christmas the prime minister wants to be
remembered for keeping his promise to
those who gifted him with a landslide
if he doesn't the season of good will
he's enjoyed so far in towns like ghoul
could rapidly freeze into a winter of
discontent
trevor phillips sky news ghoul
just a reminder that trevor will be here
later this morning on trevor phillips on
sunday and his guests today include
justice secretary dominic raab and you
can watch that interview live here on
sky news from 8 30 this morning and do
join the conversation also on social
media with the hashtag philips
just to update you on some breaking news
that's coming in reports from indonesia
say that seven people are missing
following the serious volcanic eruption
at least 13 people have died after mount
ceremony erupted following heavy rain
and dozens more people have been taken
to hospitals so that's the latest there
seven people are missing following that
serious volcanic eruption in indonesia
and at least 13 people have died
now an enthralling formula one battle
could be decided this evening front
runner max verstappen is eight points
ahead of lewis hamilton going into the
saudi arabia grand prix and to be a
title contender it takes more than just
a fast car well i'm now joined by daniel
ricardo's performance coach
michael italiano thank you very much
indeed for your time this morning so
that is the big question isn't it what
does it take then to perform at the
highest level
yeah good morning vanessa um that's a
good question um
formula one is i guess
a sport that's very very uh physically
and mentally demanding that not many
people actually know about so um yeah
it's
the big one is g-force obviously g-force
is a you know the gravitational pull
that these guys experience with these
extremely
fast cars
um and then you've also got the the high
temperatures that these guys have to uh
deal with being in a cockpit at like 50
degrees in uh fire resistant uh racing
suits
so uh
keeping the body cool is actually very
difficult as well
and then you've got the the
concentration factor when they've got
you know 20 buttons on the steering
wheel and they're trying to drive this
car as fast as they can for for two
hours
it's uh it's it's very demanding and uh
this race circuit in in general the
saudi arabian race circuit is uh
is going to be it's going to be it's
going to be a big one it's very fast
there's about 27 corners so uh i think
we're gonna see uh plenty of action
today
so talk us through some of the work that
you do with daniel
yeah so so my job as a performance coach
is pretty much to prepare him to perform
so i'm with him uh every
race weekend so i'm doing his uh his
training his nutrition and uh and also
he's mental coaching so there's there's
quite a lot involved but we're with each
other probably about 270 days of the
year we're with each other a lot so you
also have to get along with your driver
as well
now as spectators we probably
underestimate the physical demands of an
f1 driver can you just give us some
insight for example how many hours did
they dedicate to the gym each week
yeah it's i mean we're training every
day
especially the neck the neck is the the
one main muscle that experiences the
most g-force across across a race so
why you need to keep your neck
strong is because usually when these
guys are driving
to be able to judge a corner you know
your head and your eye line needs to be
straight and level uh if your neck's not
strong and your head is moving side to
side uh you're not going to drive very
smoothly you're going to lose lap time
so keeping the neck strong is uh is very
important so a lot of hours in the gym
a lot a lot of neck training which is uh
it's just quite quite fun to do and uh
and a lot of cardiovascular training as
well a lot of running uh we've been with
a lot of hiking as well
and i can speak with authority that i do
none of that at all and i spend zero
hours in the gym now this is the one of
the closest finishes to the drivers
championship so who is your pick then
for the title
yeah look i'm gonna
i'm gonna go with experience i i think
lewis would do it in my opinion i think
uh i think he's you know seven-time
world champ he knows how to win he knows
how to get it done so yes he's eight
points behind but
i do think he's gonna i do think he's
gonna do it
and daniel has openly talked about his
mental health problems this year hasn't
he and is there any work that you do
with him to help him to manage this
yeah yeah unfortunately julicova we
haven't been able to go back home to
australia to see family and friends and
that's something we're not really used
to because usually you know we will see
them throughout the year
so uh yeah a little bit of homesickness
has kicked in i won't lie um and you
know it's important i think to make sure
that you have a very close-knit
internal group of a team that's uh you
know can be uh supportive to you can be
a sounding board and just uh i guess
just make sure you be there for each
other so that's one thing that daniel
does have he has a strong internal
internal team um i think also having
your hobbies outside of formula one also
helps mentally as well just to make sure
that we can actually just zone out of f1
because it can be a bit of an emotional
roller coaster at times so we do have
our hobbies um and just just to be mates
and just be friends and just do fun
things um because the calendar can be so
demanding
and also you've known daniel for a long
time haven't you just tell us how long
have you known him how long have you
worked with him for
i've known him since i was 13. we've
been working together for just over four
years now so we do have that a bit of an
advantage to our you know on our side
especially during cover times and when
we are feeling homesick you know we are
mates so there are times where we just
be mates and and do fun stuff together
and just try and uh
i guess trying to ignore the the
external pressures of not being a c
family and uh and you know the demanding
nature of formula one itself fantastic
stuff thank you so much indeed for your
time michael italiano here's daniel
ricardo's performance
well with us this morning to review the
papers are the anthropologist marianna
hotter and the broadcaster gemma forte
and they join me now thank you very much
indeed it's good to see both of you
let's just kick off with um f1 actually
i've just been speaking to um one of our
guests on f1 which is very big day but
um
hamilton lewis hamilton and this whole
um talk of um links with grenfell i'll
come to you there um gemma just shed
some light on this for us
okay so it turns out that one of the
sponsors that was going to be all over
hamilton's car for branding wise as
kingspan now kingspan supplied the
combustible insulation that was on the
grenfell towers of course which that
tragedy was as recent as 2017 of course
and it's still extremely
raw and a very very sensitive subject
for so many reasons so there was a lot
of alarm a lot of dismay and um i do
understand louis hamilton he's in pole
position i'd imagine in this particular
sport as well it's so dangerous and the
focus is on the sport and yet it's a bit
disingenuous i think to sort of say oh
well it wasn't my decision which i'm
sure it wasn't that he's kind of came
out and said well it's nothing to do
with me the teams sign the sponsors the
only one i've ever brought to the table
was tommy hilfiger
um so it was almost a bit reluctant to
get embroiled with it however i think
when you're
such a powerful
figure in sport you have such a huge
reputation
it is down to you to to be involved and
you know you're going to be driving in
that car it is you are the brand you are
the face you are the name you are the
sports person so you know perhaps do get
involved with who you're going to use as
sponsors going forward and and have that
involvement
absolutely that's a strong message there
actually you can't just take a back seat
can you you've got to be play more of an
active role in there um marianne i'll
come to you with this next story because
covered
is here covert is here did we know this
at all but all in one test could detect
covert flu and lung viruses
this sounds impressive stuff just tell
us more about this
yeah this is a really interesting piece
of um
cutting edge science really so the
company
lots of pharmaceutical companies are
involved in um obviously creating
vaccines and creating all those testing
kits that we have knocking around the
house or when you have to go and get a
pcr test uh because you've got symptoms
um so one of the companies that produces
the pcr tests that we're currently using
that are being used on our behalf in
laboratories
is developing a test or has now
developed a test that could do a um what
they're calling a winter panel so that
you do the same kind of nose and throat
swab and then it would be tested not
just for covered um the covid virus but
also for the common cold and also
another common respiratory virus called
rsv
um we don't specifically need to know
what that is but basically the situation
that lots of us are in at the moment and
have been for the past few months of
kind of going well i've got this
headache
i've got mild
flu fluid cold symptoms don't know is
that covered is it a cough or a cold
that my kid picked up at school
some people are going ah maybe it's all
right it's probably not covered some
people don't maybe it is covered and
panicking
and obviously there's a knock-on
implication for how disruptive that is
for our
day-to-day lives uh the impact on on our
health care systems so perhaps a test
like this would be able to in one go
eliminate covid and also potentially
tell you what you do have so if it's
common cold then go home wrap up warm uh
paracetamol
you know a hot lemon drink and and you
know have an evening in um if it's
covered then obviously take the the
necessary precautions so this is very
exciting um and
you know hats off to our research
scientists once again
for leading us through uh this global
crisis absolutely my goodness are we so
thankful indeed um let me come to the
next story with you um gemma because
this is a story about storm irwin a week
on and so many people still don't have
any power and actually interestingly i
spoke to tim farron yesterday on this
program and he's the mp for westmoreland
and lonsdale and something that he said
he said if this had happened in
kensington for example then boris
johnson would have reacted quicker
what's your take on this
well quite possibly as you say if it
happened maybe in the home counties or
sorry
maybe he would have bothered to go there
i mean remember when we had the flooding
and and it took him days and days to to
bother going and i think it's when
you're you're talking about leveling up
as part of an agenda this really doesn't
show that you're taking that seriously
because this storm arwin and this
horrible outage of power has affected
thousands of homes in the northeast and
scotland
and when you think how cold it is at the
moment i mean i have to caveat this with
thinking about homeless people at the
moment as well of course the minute the
temperatures drop this low your heart
does go out to them
and i i had a boiler break once when i
had a newborn years ago and we were just
without um heat for a couple of days
and it was i've never forgotten it it
was so miserable
um you know we were sleeping in coats
and and again you really think about
homeless people but my heart goes out
there's going to be elderly people
vulnerable people people with newborn
babies people with small children just
people full stop who will be absolutely
desperate at this point and um
lots of people saying this is all to do
with bad infrastructure lack of
investment
finding it difficult to find parts
to be replaced because they're so old
but you just think in 2021 for people
thousands of people to be without power
for this long i can't imagine how they
must be feeling what a miserable period
and i hope that it's resolved quickly
and yes ed miliband's been criticizing
the government as well and saying
exactly what you said uh sort of
reiterating what tim farron said
absolutely well let's just show you the
northern power grid website actually and
this shows the current situation at the
moment so you can see the number of
people still without power and actually
this morning one of my guests that i i
spoke to this morning one of the
councillors um councillor for rothbury
actually said that
reports that there are more homes that
have been cut off overnight and we will
definitely be following that we are
actually live in northumberland after
eight o'clock so he's staying right
across that for you and this next story
that i'll come to you this is something
that we've been
hearing about and we we know we've been
seeing happening um marianne and i'll
come to you there banks will be
disappearing from all uk high streets by
2032. and the horror you know until you
are running around looking for a bank
and you can't find her which is the
experience i've had recently and you
realize that most of the banks in your
high streets are just gone
yeah that's right so uh in 2015 there
were almost 9 000
and by this summer uh tsb have announced
that they're going to close 70 more
branches and so the number will be down
to four and a half thousand
um there are already areas that have no
branches of bank and to some extent i
mean having a bank branch is is neither
here nor there if it's not your bank
um
fundamentally obviously there's a a huge
social societal shift now to a cashless
um transactions
people don't use checks anymore so there
are fewer of those um over-the-counter
transactions you don't need to go into
the bank quite so regularly as perhaps
you you might have wants
but that's incumbent on being um
digitally connected that you can access
your bank through
your phone or online that you have those
skills that you have that confidence
that you know that you um that you can
navigate that system and that's not true
of everybody and it it kind of it ties
in as well to this whole leveling up
agenda not so much north south in this
circumstance but in people who either
have the the kind of means to to have a
kind of smartphone they can update their
apps that they're confident that they've
got that digital um literacy
versus people who might not have had
those advantages and don't have those
skill sets and so
to some extent you go well that's the
nature of things banking is going to
move online that's fine but
that has to come with hand in hand with
alternative services being provided for
people who elderly people for example
who want to access their pension and
don't want to have to go to a cash
machine get all their cash out stand in
the high street trying to get it in
their bag
and and be vulnerable in in that regard
and we need to actually support people
to do this digital transition
safely and confidently otherwise we're
leaving people behind
absolutely and um let me just very
quickly go to you we're running out of
time but gemma i'll come to you very
quickly because we want to end with some
music a bit of techno music from berlin
yes this is berlin's dj he's gathering
together
trying to get cultural heritage status
for techno so that they can protect it
so that clubs can stay open so they can
get funding and that it's seen as a
legitimate social force this has
happened for amsterdam's pride it's
happened for jamaica and reggae it also
happens for things like slovakian
bagpiping and more traditional forms of
music but it's basically saying techno
is important it's a big positive force
it brings people together and we need to
keep these destinations open
thank you so much indeed to both of you
marianna hutter gemma four today thank
you so much i'll be back after this
break
[Music]